[Music]
all of these ideas can work
there's no rules and ig's a day or
there's not a lot of time like 45
seconds not not edited just go and film
it that's way easier than producing a
podcast or going up and do men in the
street and then editing it like so much
easier and and it speaks to your skill
set and strengths that feeds you
yeah
and starts to relieve some of the stress
around money and it's the most effective
way to build your brand just post
hi
liz grant in the house how you doing so
well thank you so much this is so
amazing it looks beautiful where you are
i know i made it that way because the
other way is kind of ugly
oh you know what
huh do you know how i heard that is when
when you said i made it that way it's
like you made the weather that way
i've been working on that too i like it
ellie's like wow i like liz is thinking
bigger here this is i made it that way
can you come to toronto because it's
raining right now we could use rain in
california though i made it that way i
love it cool well welcome back to mova
makers this is um
awesome having you back in i love you i
love your energy and your vibe and your
smile and and
how can i help what do you got thank you
so much well i want to do this first if
you'll let me i'm using my time um so
these are the top 12 things i've learned
from evan so 12 is that 12 000 videos
later you're likely to still have
resistance filming but just film and
post
11 is the equipment doesn't matter just
post
10 is nobody cares about your makeup
just post i don't believe that one but
um
nine do it because you may inspire
someone uh like you who's five years
behind where you are now
um
clean your house because research shows
that you're more stressed when it's
cluttered
seven get outside start moving videos
are easy when you feel like you're
moving or talking to someone or in a
parking lot at costco while you're
waiting for your wife to finish shopping
nina
um
have courage feel the fear and post
anyway
five keep going um have one business
model which is what i'd love to talk to
you about and stick with that until you
get some success and then start trying
to do everything else um
serve others serve a higher purpose
believe and you've shown me i'm gonna
get emotional but you show me you
believe in me and it means so much to me
also my mom and my stepdad who've made
some tremendous sacrifices so i can be
in movement makers like canceling disney
plus
um
and number one if you're not posting
it's probably because you're just
spiritually constipated
you just need to get going you need some
momentum and we need to get your book i
love it well first off what an amazing
list thank you for the tribute i
appreciate you liz that's that's
fantastic i'm speechless i'm just taking
it in thank you oh thank you for
everything so well let's dive in how do
you mean what do you got how can i help
what do we want to work on business
model posting yeah well i'm a bit of a
mess with posting i'm having trouble
with my computers both of them don't
seem to be able to handle basic
editing and imovie is a nightmare for
doing like i'll film a long set and i
just want to splice all those up and
post them
and
i'm having trouble i've tried all
different apps i
and
i've tried just doing it on the phone so
i i just got a gal from fiverr
to help me and she loves comedy and
she's got good comedic timing so i don't
think i need to tell her in and out
points
and um and i think i can afford her for
a little bit she's super cheap she's a
student so um
so that's like at some point i'd love
some guidance on i even downloaded the
open source software
for video editing and i can't even
launch that on my
computer so
but i really feel like um i'm confused
about
well right now what we what jessica and
i were doing when we were working
together and i could afford her was we
were trying to get corporate comedy gigs
so that i could secure that income
and um it's really hard through linkedin
to try to message people who don't want
to hear from you you know and whatever
and i'd love to be able to run ads on
linkedin
but i don't think i have the money right
now to do that
um so what i pivoted to
most recently the economy just as you
know something happened on top of a
bunch of other things happening and
i um
started doing shows online which
is just to my facebook friends and i
just said hey if you feel like
tipping or not whatever and that was how
i was able to pay my rent like it was
really successful and
i have a lot of different topics that i
was doing shows for like i have pets
and then i have um dating material and
then so of all these different themes
um and i was just making it quick
because no one really wants to be on
zoom that much
so i was just doing like quick 20 minute
um
sets and just riffing with people and
having a good time and
and i was just blown away it was way
more than if i would have sold tickets
you know
so what i'm wondering is
should i keep and then also um doing
shows in people's backyards
so
the same thing just like okay you know
you want to tip me and and the joke is
that i have two netflix specials but
netflix doesn't know about it yet
so i've been trying to figure out well
what um
branding or what persona do i want and i
and maybe it doesn't even matter but i i
feel like they're two really different
shows and i have two really different
podcast ideas
so i don't know really what i should be
doing so nothing gets done and if you go
back to the list of the 12 things
yeah a lot of it was like
just post
[Laughter]
i i hear you in my head yes absolutely
and here's like you know
in watching some of your stuff and
looking at you're even looking at your
ig before going on here
you know you posted
a couple times this month
and it doesn't have to be you
on stage it could just be you
talking to the camera i mean it's social
commentary your stuff is you you see
something
i'm sure hanging out with you there'd be
there'd be jokes all day
your comments if you like riffing with
people in your facebook group then all
of those that becomes content yeah and
honestly be looking at
three posts a day
across tik tok and instagram okay
which starts to build your brand because
you all you need is for one of those to
pop that somebody says
who is this person who is this liz woman
i've never heard of her before and then
they start diving into everything else
that you're doing
i love the betting on yourself when
doing your own shows
you know like asking for donations doing
your shows if the model becomes these
are is this inside a facebook group or
this is just your facebook friends
that's my facebook friends i just put
something on there and then invited
people
i'd love to take this show on the road
like even if it's still you just in your
home or wherever you are doing like how
do we expand it beyond your facebook
friends
so that when people are watching this or
people who are watching your content
when they see it they know that there's
a show happening
whether it's every week or every two
weeks or once a month or i don't know
how long it it takes you to kind of get
ready or if you're just jamming with
people
and riffing then you could you could do
a weekly show yeah yeah and i have
enough material to do weekly shows and
do themed shows and topics like i have i
have 35 minutes on costco that
you know i could do a whole thing on
costco
i want to hear that one that'd be good
uh but the way you're doing it right now
is people would have to
be your facebook friend to be able to
see the show correct right right so we
need something a little more
open whether it's a facebook the easiest
thing might just be a facebook group
oh
where you launch your own facebook group
okay you can still invite people in
and then you go live inside that
facebook group
once a week you've got your friday night
special or or whatever it is was there a
certain time you're doing them
no but mostly like saturdays 7 30 okay
saturday 7 30. yeah you can ask your
friends and post on your facebook to
people to join the group yeah so hey i'm
joining this group i'm having this group
you know liz grant comedy come join in
and the next time we do my show you'll
be the first to know
and then anybody who follows you you've
got almost a thousand followers right
now on instagram
you send a video message to everybody
one by one say hey i'm starting a new
i'm starting a new group okay
come join me and make that the link in
your bio
okay
so what i want to do
what i want to do what my idea is i
guess for you my my invitation to you
there instead of like hey you have to do
this liz is
taking two paths right one is let's
build the liz grant we got to build your
brand up people need to know about you
which will lead to lots of opportunities
whether it's a a netflix show corporate
gigs can you come speak at my event we
need somebody to open for our
event whatever like people will just
think you're funny and then find ways to
include you in the stuff that they're
doing but they have to know who you are
and they have to find you and they have
to think you're funny right
so that's the three times a day posting
okay tick tock and instagram reels
okay and it's just
like you find something and you get
inspired and you make a
you make something quick and funny and
and not having like don't worry about
the edit there is no editing no edits
zero edits
okay like you you're you open it up and
you
you film from your phone
you know 45 seconds to a minute you're
outside costco and you get upset at
something
you film it and then you post it to tick
tock and to instagram reels
three times a day instagram reels
instagram reels and tick tock three
times a day
okay stuff that's happening here's my
breakfast and what's so funny about the
oatmeal it looks like a whatever and
then you just and right yeah
something just quick
okay
one you'll get better at it like you're
already great at what you do but like in
in how do you tell like
micro 45 second jokes but also knowing
that there's three coming up tomorrow
too you're less concerned about this one
having to be so great and edited
perfectly it's like whatever i don't
even remember what i did last week
because there's so much that you're
you're creating today and tomorrow
totally and then some of those will hit
and some of them will then lead to
people wanting to find out about you
okay
so that is building the brain but that
is a i mean it's the consistent work to
put in and you never know when
something's gonna hit
right so that but but that's like our
we're we're we're taking our at bats you
know we're taking our bats until we get
a a single or double or a home run right
yep yep but if you're not swinging
you're not stepping up you're not gonna
get any hits right
uh meanwhile so that like that's gonna
lead to big things for you and things
that you can't even predict at this
point
yeah
somebody like wants you to do
uh to open for them on stage somebody
wants you to
do the set at their wedding some like
you never know you know their their pets
are getting married and they want you to
come and
who knows like
crazy things will happen you know a new
costco opens and they want you to be the
oh
that would be heaven you want to open it
up like you never know where it's going
to go honestly because of what you do
there's there's no one defined path only
for you it's not like you only have to
have a book and that's the only way that
you can win exactly so that's why you
need to have so many at bats out there
and lots of ways that people can can
find you and different angles and paths
through yeah so that helps build your
brain
but how do you how do you feed yourself
and pay the bills and all that well
that's through your weekly specials okay
that we're driving people towards now
okay so the link in your bio you have
you have a bio link on instagram if you
buy a link on tick tock you link them
both to your facebook group
and it's like join me for my weekly
comedy special okay cool
and then when people show up then that's
when you do your usual thing and you're
asking for tips and donations and
explaining where you're at and also ask
for help it's like
when you're asking for the donations or
the tips i like tips better than
donations me too yeah ask them for help
it's like hey if anybody knows
you know if
somebody needs a comedian to open up for
their
wedding or their event or their xyz
yeah keep me in mind
because people may not even know to
think about like they love you they just
had a laugh but they don't they don't
even know how they might be able to help
that's true
so as part of a tip you you also have a
call to action
yeah and that's a very simple like to
set up a facebook group you can do that
today
i know you don't need to have any fancy
like you need a computer with chrome
okay and you go to facebook set up a
group and there it is the liz grant
comedy group okay and you already know
how to go live inside facebook so cool
so now that's just going to go live
inside your facebook group
and now we want to get people in
so it's not just your friends watching
you but other people who now are going
to discover you well i was thinking
about trying to capture their email
through the lead magnet and then do it
on zoom but um
what do you think about that
i just don't want to add layers of
complexity for you okay i appreciate
that you can
you know like this might be liz grant in
in a year
but like i want to get you moving and i
want to get you paid
yeah
and those two things will allow lots of
other things to happen
you're right like to create a lead
magnet and then create a landing page
and then to create the
email tie-ins and all that it's like
yeah you could you could do that but
you're probably gonna
be frustrated by it yeah yeah you're
right i got a real short attention span
and low frustration tolerance for sure
so i'd rather you spend that time making
three ig reels and three tick tocks a
day and then doing your weekly show
so it's like
the most basic of
of business plans but it's super easy
for you to execute yeah it is you just
have a facebook group
you just say you're going live every
whatever friday at 7 30 or saturday at
whatever
yeah and then you message all your
friends
to join you there and you and you
message your all your followers on
instagram
like do do 30 people a day
okay send a quick video message
and say hey
susan thank you for following me i
appreciate it i've started a new
facebook group and in there i'm going
live
uh once a week with my comedy show i
hope you can join me the link's in my
bio happy monday
believe i would add to believe at the
end you don't have to
hashtag evan carmichael i mean that's
what i do every morning every morning i
go for a walk i like it when i'm moving
around outside and i'm
not just in my office like i like the
nature and the energy
so i'll go for a walk and i'll send 30
to 50
dms over video every day sometimes the
move makers sometimes they're friends
sometimes they're people who followed me
just a lot of random stuff um
yeah and like today i was walking
outside in my undershirt and a weighted
vest on and i'm walking around with this
making videos in the park you know it's
like
go it's that like that's the best yeah
so if you have a thousand followers
you know you do 30 people a day just let
them know about what you're doing and
that's that facebook group page is the
default link in your bio for anything
that you're creating yeah and then
right now it's a little bit of hustle to
like actual manual outreach like you're
going to ask your friends and you're
going to ask all your followers one by
one not a post because the post nobody's
going to see it but a dm people see
okay and they're already following you
so it's not like we're spamming people
it's like hey susan thank you for
following me yeah i've started a new
facebook group i'm doing my show once a
week there i'd love to have you if you
want to join the links in my bio happy
monday next like
doing 30 of those is not
it's not that difficult and then as
we're making three reels and three tick
tocks a day that's now the group that
people are going to go to by default
so they're going to watch your thing
who's this liz grant and then they see
the link they click on it they join your
group
and then we use the weekly show
as your chance to start making like a
little bit of money and then more money
and then more money and then people love
you and people find opportunities and
then the world opens up where you're
yeah doing all sorts of crazy things
makes sense
people just don't know you enough yeah i
know
um
okay that's great so what about um in
terms of a podcast um
i know this can be super complicated i
do not think that i can produce it
myself like if i got someone else who
was
interested in handling all the technical
and the posting and the audio because i
started doing um it was called massaging
comedy so and i am a massage therapist
but um i'm massage comedians so
um we had one really good show but the
problem was i need more equipment
because the audio levels were too
different
so um
so i don't know if i should like
continue down with that podcast or just
do a podcast about how to make things
funner or fun that i find or interview
fun and funny people or
don't worry about it and just work on
what you the assignment you just gave me
i would definitely work on the
assignment i just gave you first okay
that is like because that feeds you
yeah
and starts to relieve some of the stress
around money and it and it's the most
effective way to build your brand
because we now need more people to find
you now if you're saying i got this evan
this is easy like dm 30 people a day who
follow me cool set up the facebook group
that's done today and three tick tocks a
day and ig reels no problem like done
cool
what's next yeah you want to do a
podcast awesome or you want to do
something else that's in that
genius head of yours cool
thank you but let's let's get the first
part
down like that's the foundation for you
building
both the short-term business and the
long-term business for you
yeah you're right
what do you think about tick-tock um
lives where you do battles with people
or i was thinking about even doing like
i have so many jokes on on cards so like
when i do like comedy tarot like oh this
joke's for you
i like it uh tick tock tick tock lives
are interesting um i still like
instagram lives more but tick tock is
uh it's worth playing in and having fun
with with the lives the the best part
about doing the live sorry the the just
posting regulated tick tock or ig reels
is it could be the same video
so the 45 second cost code joke that
you're gonna tell you film it with your
phone
vertical and then you can post it to
both tik tok and instagram vertical okay
yeah has to be vertical so like what we
just talked about
uh that's that's the assignment for the
next you know three to six months
and make me like that has to happen
every day
okay like that's our that's our basic
past that's like brushing your teeth
has to happen every day you know i hope
uh
[Laughter]
that has to happen if you're gonna then
look at other things
i would i would default to the ones that
are exciting for you okay
that you can also do without needing
tons of gear equipment team production
because that's when things start to get
overwhelming and impossible yeah
so
doing a tick tock live is so much easier
to do than to do a massage therapy
joke set up with
three cameras and multiple microphones
and everything else
what do you think about um
man on the street stuff like how how
difficult is that to produce with good
audio and because we just kind of tried
it but we were getting ambient noise
so is it a two like if we had one of
those little zoom things that's portable
and then two mics
would that be sufficient
so it depends one depends on how good
you are man on the street stuff right
and how much do you like and is it fun
pretty good good so that's a good start
uh two then the easiest way to start is
with just with a single microphone just
make sure it has like a a cover like a
windscreen yeah it's kind of a way
and so your pat you hold it and you pass
it back and forth but the problem with
that is that's the easiest thing to do
the challenge with that is
uh if if they say something while you're
talking or you you you have to make sure
that the voices always come in here or
you don't hear it exactly so if you have
the mic on them and you want to crack
some joke you have to bring it back to
you so there's a little bit of getting
used to that
but also like man on the street if if
you need them to come in and then you're
going to mic them up
you've already lost it right if you want
to have a second mic that then you're
they have to hold yeah it adds a level
of complexity
um but the easiest thing you still need
a camera person
and then you need you need the
microphone right so the microphone's not
that expensive
basic microphone with a like a
windscreen is a couple bucks like it
doesn't have to cost a lot but we're
adding levels of complexity now where
you have to have somebody with you yeah
who's going to set up the camera and
film it for you
and then there's editing
out all of the
moments and waiting and you know so
that's a fun project
like you put that into the fun bucket
which is good like fun is great you know
it's like we add that on top of the
on top of the the daily you know what
we're doing all of these ideas can work
there's no rules right i mean
for me that would suck for me to like
walk up on someone on somebody said hey
and like have some joke to tell them oh
my gosh
it is awful no you know what i have to
tell you i'm actually i guess i'm an
ambivert but it's horrifying but when
like jessica and i we normally riff and
i just started talking to people and
then if that's what but but approaching
people is is horrifying but i thought
about people with dogs like i could
roast your dog
um
things like that but um
it wound up being you know like i wound
up having deep conversations with some
people it started off you know some of
it was funny but you're right it needed
to be edited the funny part needed to be
edited afterwards so
if you're gonna roast somebody i would
honestly look at like look at news
like load up google news and see what's
trending and roast whoever roast bite
and roast trump roast
putin like whatever is the front page of
google news or front page of the new
york times every day as long as you have
enough to say about it you pull it up
and you put the camera on on the page
like again it doesn't have to be edited
you take your phone
show the screen and say
biden
whatever you wanna i think i think
fitness stuff is funny i think the whole
because i'm into it but i mean it's like
it's a bit difficult to you know take it
also very seriously you know all the
wellness movement you know
but um i think that's a fun thing to
make or to roast there's two buckets
there's the like the blocking and
tackling this has to happen there's the
daily has to happen it's like you
wouldn't go outside naked you got to put
some clothes on right so like this is
our this is liz putting her clothes on
is we're gonna do the three tick tocks
and ig reels a day we're gonna do a
weekly show inside of our facebook group
we're gonna ask for tips and we're gonna
ask for help and like hey if you know
anybody who needs a community to open up
that's our that's our getting dressed
every day okay and then after that's
done then fun whatever yeah man on the
street rose some fitness influencers
load up google news and all of that can
work there's no rules with that just
defaulted trying to get into action mode
as opposed to oh here's an idea but then
instantly like oh there's all these
reasons why i can't do it because i need
you know me so well this is a that
you're
telling me everything that like it's
you're breaking it down so simply it's
really helpful because i mean i thought
well that's ridiculous that i can't do
x y and z thing because i can see it i
can see all these things and you know
but to actually implement them i mean
it's it is overwhelming for me
well and just understand that it's not a
no
it's just a not yet yeah
there's a sequence that's all because
if you get if you just do the the block
and the with the basics that we talked
about
then you start to build enough money to
pay your rent and pay your bills and and
then and then build more money to hire a
team who can then help you do all this
stuff right and so these are all the
ideas that are round two when you have
budget and you have one person to help
you and then round three will be even
bigger things in round four and then liz
is at a giant stadium selling it out you
know so
there's it's not no it's not that it's
not possible it's totally possible yeah
it's just a lot easier to go in sequence
and so it's not yet because if you get
that those first things down that then
you can afford to hire a team then
everything else becomes a lot easier
afterwards
were you going to say something else
because you said there's two there's two
pieces one you said this was the
brushing the teeth thing or whatever and
i don't know what the other thing was
well in in the brushing the teeth it
does the brush and teeth does two things
it gets you paid
yes because you're asking for tips and
asking for help but it's also building
your brand
because now if you're doing three a day
on both tick tock and instagram reels
more people will start to discover you
and great things will happen from that
that you can't expect
like you can expect great things but you
don't know where it's gonna go yeah
should i even try to deal with uh
linkedin
uh i wouldn't worry about linkedin too
much
because everyone's on their phone
looking at tick-tock
yeah and like that's what works like if
you only did tick-tock instagram or be
worried because it's like where does it
like it's a
it's like a it's a hope and pray thing
it's like okay if i keep doing it
eventually it's gonna work out and it
will but like when's it gonna work out
evan's like oh i don't know like you
gotta keep going but one of them will
pop and we'll hit
but if you can combine it with the
facebook group
where you're doing a weekly show and
getting tips and getting paid yeah now
we have a fantastic
one-two punch strategy yeah and and that
honestly doesn't even take a ton of time
no i know that's the problem
and ig's a day or is not a lot of time
like 45 seconds not not edited just go
and film it
is not an insane amount of time
especially once you get into the the
rhythm and habit of it that's way easier
than producing a podcast or going up and
do men in the street and then editing it
like so much easier and and it speaks to
your skill set and strengths yeah
and most importantly start getting the
momentum that you need
yeah
you're so right now it's time to act hey
i love it this is great in the house
appreciate you thank you for the love
thank you so much
we've got alain in the house alain's
been with mover makers and as part of
that we do uh this ig live together
welcome la so i mean what do you got how
can i help what's on your mind the one
question i think i will talk today is
the idea of how because i'm a teacher
and in some ways i'm an employee and
when we talk about movement makers who
are trying to go and
uh
be of service in the outside than the
idea of entrepreneur but i find it so
hard to go from a mindset of an employee
to a mindset of an entrepreneur i'm
trying all kind of things and i pretty
much mess everything but part of the
learning
and i was thinking of uh
some of the stories you may have on when
you were an employee and then i knew
that you did a switch and it was a shift
where you said okay this is what i'm
doing and then i'm sailing forward
so i don't have much experience as an
employee i did not work for a company
for very long before doing my business
and i have to go back to my university
days when when i was an employee so like
being a student not a not not that i was
a teacher anything um i just remember i
was at a job i was on the team of five
people
and um i get headaches with fluorescent
lighting and um get like blood sugar
issues and so i have to eat uh and
i was bringing food to the office and
they didn't they didn't like it they
didn't like that i was eaten in the
office and i remember i had to have um a
disc man back in the day before mp3
players
and i wasn't allowed to listen to music
any either it was like super boring work
like copy pasting data entries super
boring stuff and so remember i would
bring music bring my dismay and put on
the floor and run i bought an extra long
um
headphone connection that went from
i put it through my jeans up through my
turtleneck and i'd always wear
turtlenecks every day and then just have
the little thing that popped out here so
i can listen to music while i did this
really boring work
and i remember i was about to get fired
i never went to the lunches i never went
out with my co-workers and they were
about to fire me and then they looked at
the results and i had done more work
than the other four combined on my team
like me i did more work than all four of
my other teammates combined i don't know
what they were doing slacking off and
again it is boring and i just realized
that this is it's too much politics in
inside of a job and just not um
not interesting and like they reward the
wrong things at least the company that i
was at you know but it sounds like a
fairly common experience i think the key
though you know back to the questions is
being in entrepreneurial groups so i
mean movement makers is great to be a
part of
amazing
reading books watching videos like
making it part of the daily routine to
consume some kind of content and then is
there anything you can do at the school
to
like the kids are some of the most
entrepreneurial people
i know yes like everybody wants to be an
entrepreneur now
when we were in high school it just
wasn't nobody even knew what the word
entrepreneur meant
um but now everybody wants to be an
entrepreneur so what about even like an
entrepreneur club or an entrepreneur
group or something for the kids so that
it's in your actual
ecosystem as opposed to just uh
when you go home it's funny because if
you uh i think it's last semester
actually instead of having students to
give me a presentation like the usual i
told them i wanted them to create a
website with their and their end
presentation and just tell me about
their website and i know there was an
aspect where there was the content but
just the learning of a website i thought
was they need to do that so that they
can go outside of the school because
school system is a great place to be but
it's nice when you can apply what you
learn and show the world what you can do
like any job us you have some degree of
flexibility and some things where you
can't control you you can't control the
curriculum right like you have to teach
what is government mandated to teach but
there is some degree of flexibility in
what happens after school or even the
examples you're using or
um even rituals in the class or maybe
what's on the wall like maybe you have
entrepreneurial quotes all over the home
room you know that you're in yeah um
the assignments are projects or clubs or
after school stuff like there's some i
mean teachers there's so many great
teachers i think also get a really bad
knock like there's
it's more the edu education system
that's a problem than the teachers that
are the problem like there's so many
great teachers who would like deeply
care about their students and who badly
want them to win and are and they're
frustrated that they can't do more to
help because they're being told what to
do
it's funny because i think it's a
marketing thing i think that's a
marketing issue if you think about it we
all do our things in a small classroom
that students are doing their work but
often it's
it's not
projected out where we can just show
other others of the world what we can do
because it's like a portfolio
like for me youtube is a portfolio of
what i can do so and students can learn
doing that as well you don't need to
have a resume on a piece of paper you
can actually show what you have what you
produce like the content we always talk
about create content and so on that's
something they can do as with as long as
they stay safe and their identity is
protected and so on so that's always
something to keep in mind
yeah i think ev every kid wants to be a
youtuber so
when they see
you know when they see their teacher has
a youtube channel even if it's not that
big but even that you're trying and
you're creating yeah it already forms a
point of connection versus
everybody else
it's funny because i always show them
because i have a
youtube channel for my science class and
i always show them my first because i
have two i have a few channel and the
first one was a minecraft
playing like a playthrough and it was
just my voice not my face i was scared
of doing all these things then i showed
and now i'm doing face-to-face uh
face-to-face videos and then i have a
like a q a session every saturdays
but it's it's like a process of getting
better at it so i always show them the
process so they know that i'm not
they cannot see me as a final product
but they have to see the journey at the
same time yeah we often forget
i love it dude i love it and
i i learned from you on a youtube video
i got where is it listen okay let me let
me get it
i like it
you get better when you go outside
yeah so alain
you're not using it right now because i
hear some wind but i forgot i forgot
everything in the car
so alain made this i'm not i'm not much
of a gear guy right but alain made this
video in his car uh you just pulled over
on the side of the street and you made
you know it wasn't like the most
produced video but he just pulls over
press is recorded in his car and like
that sounds really good what microphone
are you using and then he sends me he
sends me the link and it was this one
and it were you using it with the with
the screen on or just like just like
this
just like this just a little bit then
actually when there's wind it's better
with the puff yeah it just looks like a
beautiful voice like you you're
professional
so i'm learning from the movement makers
as well
there you go always teaching you're
always teaching
i'm true it's funny because when you
said
like today is like a first to be outside
in in a place like this
uh i have a live like youtube live on
saturday morning so i was here so what
can i do and i decided to ch so i tried
i did experiment with my channel where i
had the live on youtube
by uh
by uh it's a power plant i said well
let's try something out of the blue and
i tried several ways of doing the videos
so i could learn okay what sounds better
how can i use my phone because i don't
have all the gears in the world so so i
have some some positive four views i'm
happy of those four views and uh but
it's going well i can see if you
experiment you can always get better
that's for sure
yeah and and i love that you're willing
to try you know i think a lot of people
just get the idea but then never do
anything with it where you are always
willing to go off and try it's back to
the mindset thing you know anytime you
want to shift the mindset it's really
much more functional environment than
anything else the fastest way to shift
the mindset is be around the people who
think the way you want to think and so
for for people who are an employee you
have your at home
rituals and then you have your your
rituals at at work and the good news is
i think like kids today are so
entrepreneurial
minded already like they're going to be
more entrepreneurial than than you might
be just in in their mindset in their way
of thinking how do you encourage that
how can you be a part of that how can
you if it's sharing your entrepreneurial
dreams or is there is there ways to
bring that into the content inside the
teaching
where they're doing research on
entrepreneurial companies i mean a lot
of teachers use my videos in their
classes and they use my books in their
classes
um
it's like i mean i never expected it but
it ended up becoming an amazing little
tradition yeah there's one teacher who's
got a great six a great seven class in
every every year they go through your
one word together and then they tweet at
me and they share what their one words
were like i never intended the book to
be designed for grade six grade seven
students but it's cool to see it being
used that way it is good actually the i
was teaching virtually for two years so
i'm going back to school so
that's that's one of my idea to try to
get the class out of your book so we can
because the one word is so important and
even though it changes at least they can
focus on what they want and how what
feels great for them
well if you do it let me know we'll get
we'll get some maybe get some signed
copies out to them or we'll do like a
zoom afterwards for the students or
whatever what what um what age group are
you working with
the grade nine and ten so that's
thirteen fourteen
um but every so often i have a grade
twelve class and they always have great
questions and
they're going from a high school life to
maybe like post-secondary or sometimes
the workforce
and uh and sometimes just having a
vision of where
where they can go or where to focus
their thoughts there's so many options
out there i feel bad sometimes for them
because for me there were fewer options
not for them it's the sky's the limit
when you think about it
so
well they're like
people said for sure
they're lucky to have a teacher like you
man who cares and wants to see them win
that's what we need to do and and also
to build confidence because it's
interesting because as i try to build
their confidence they help me as well
because they have ideas that i've never
thought of
like perspective and so on and that's
why we need to listen to teenagers more
often often we forget that we say well
we tell them what to do but they have
they have a wealth of
perspective that is amazing
i agree that's why i listen to you and i
bought the microphone
i know right
and uh
uh let's see what is the other one um i
know that the reason why i want to play
outside is uh i used to be a geologist
and i do try to play outside a bit more
and i try to tell people around me and
students that
insight is great because we're protected
between our four walls but as soon as
you go out there you need to trust
yourself a little bit more and there's
so much more you can actually accomplish
if you just give it a try
and it's a confidence matter and a
mindset as you mentioned earlier
i don't know how or why he did this but
i remember i had a history teacher in
high school grade 12 history who uh
would often take us outside for the
class like it was a really nice day he's
like wait thank you books we're going
outside and we just sit on the grass
under the under a tree and we would
teach he would teach the class outside
on the ground
um not when we had a test or anything
but just like a lecture it's like that
was that was really fun it was different
like what what are we doing why are we
not in the classroom but
yeah just just getting outside and
getting on nature i don't know it uh
made it a lot more memorable that's for
sure i should have a story for you i i
teach science and there's always a unit
on ecosystems and by the school there's
a little creek and i always used to go
there
uh just with the class so we can we can
go in the puddle and and boys and girls
would just go and step in the water it
was just this much water but just did
get back in the class all dirty but they
were hot so there was a time when the
board says for safety we cannot be too
close to the water and and the path was
close to the
close to the uh this creek
and then with my class we figured that
we could all bring all those uh
uh let's see all uh
you know when you go into a boat like
safety jackets and those
so i went to the vp saying we need to
then up floaters and a safety jacket
just to make sure the board is happy
and he says no no don't go out to the
school with banana floaters because we
all look bad and he says it's just a bit
silly but but the students were all
excited just to go outside and play but
we still do and
the
two years ago we did the
uh earthworm hunt to try to see how
the population of earthworms but just
just play with the dirt people often
inside you play with their books you're
in the desk and they forget that you
have to play a bit
so what did you do today to play evan
uh besides
live
i i i've been so i'm talking my team all
day but i just took uh a break at [ __ ]
before this i had 25 minutes and i was
out uh on the grass with my with my mini
dashind out in the backyard
uh looking at
my emails and what i had coming up but
just it's a it's a beautiful day here in
toronto it's like let's get some sun
yeah that's perfect since moving to a
house out of the condo we've been doing
a lot more grounding a lot more time
outside backyard campfires
you know barefoot on the grass
it's um
very different than the condo living
i bet i need to check the two new videos
because i've been i don't remember
seeing your new recording videos i know
you were painting and i need to see how
it looks like so
that's my my next thing in the coming
week coming week i don't know if i even
have any new videos of this place
okay that's maybe
the only the listen alan like we just
moved right so the only thing that's set
up is is that look the office is set up
because that's the first thing i have to
do right so you can kind of see
oh i see the office nice so that's set
up but everything else is just empty
[Laughter]
you're still moving in okay that's still
moving yeah i don't know it's like it's
completely it's completely unknown
amazing this is kind of set up i don't
know what this is going to become but
it's all it's all it's all empty you
know like the path outside is all empty
it's just we're still sleeping on the
floor you know we ordered a bed that
comes in four weeks or something so
the only thing that that is remotely set
up is just
the office because i got to film content
that's true yeah but the content that's
nice so i have i have not uh filmed
anything kind of showing
the house or anything yet so if you go
looking for it you won't find anything
what i just did is probably the most i
filmed so there you go you got the tour
it's a good project
it's a big project it's a big project
are you going out of the city in the in
the summer
like i just left for quebec city for a
couple days and uh and you are you going
anywhere with the world opening up it's
been crazy like everybody wants me to go
and speak at different things and i
don't want to spend
you know 50 out of 52 weeks on the road
so i'm picking one thing per month to go
to and toronto is so beautiful in the
summer that i like i'd rather go away in
february than
miss out on all the greatness that's
here
oh that makes sense actually the in the
coming the coming weeks and because it's
the summer i hope to do a
a youtube live at the the rom that's one
of my my goal and i want to do youtube
live at the ago just to just to have a
background different
and i'm trying to see i'm trying to get
up to get a small whiteboard
like maybe 30 centimeters by
45 so i can carry it around so i can if
i have to do some science i can do some
notes for uh for the youtube live so i
think that'll be nice that's it i love
that i mean but the entire world of
science
exactly i know
and i think i think i needed that i
needed the world to open up a little bit
and
it's nice
because otherwise we're inside you're
doing great videos inside but for
science when you kind of touch and apply
it it's always i find it more fun i mean
just around you is a thousand different
science videos if you want to explain
physics or geometry or i mean it's all
it's all there
a little i like the little uh
the little pocket uh
white board and you do a little mini
lesson
a little mini science lesson as you go
yep and that and that's a beauty i know
that i always have a few people watching
my lives all the time and always bring
questions and it makes it nice why are
you doing youtube live though
that's a good question there's a few
reasons first i like to be able to
answer questions for people that have
them so it's a bit like the teacher live
thing
second i find it's less work for editing
the video if i do it live and sometimes
i don't always have time to edit them
and
and third
sometimes i was running out of ideas and
i said well let's get people to give me
ideas and that idea is from you evan
people say oh i look at comments of
people and answer questions and i
thought it would be nice
um so and that's once a week on saturday
morning i already have 1600
subs i'm a few thousand away
like a thousand fold smaller than you
but it's going there slowly
and uh but it's good this summer i want
to do more videos and content and so on
so i love it dude i love it and if you
need the interaction it's great the only
thing with the youtube live is once the
live is done youtube doesn't promote it
anymore
like if you ever go to a search page or
you look at suggested or the homepage
you may see it when it's live but
afterwards you'll never see a live
broadcast almost never see a live
broadcast youtube really destroys lives
in their algorithm after it's done
okay
so a strategy to go live is you could go
live and then unlisted afterwards
and then download it
and edit a second of it and then put it
up as a regular video or just edit out
the beginning like a quick edit of just
deleting are we live i mean i know how
you start like
is this working in the shaky you know um
yeah
and then put that up as a video because
the lessons you're teaching are still
relevant in three months and six months
in a year
so and that's something i have to look
into for uh maybe having an editor
because i usually i try to do live
between 30 and 60 minutes okay and i
have to both subjects so because i can
have chapters in the videos
because i've done that so sometimes i go
through stream stream yard and download
the video then i upload it and use
chapters so i hope that the search will
go well
um but i think i would like to see if i
can take that those long one-hour videos
and cut it down in shorter sections
for uh for instagram for example if i
want to do that or just have shorts on
youtube these uh these are things i need
to look into so yeah you could i did
if you're not going to do it yourself
then once you add complexity of having
somebody else whether that's somebody
you hire or like a formal student that
you really liked or whatever um
but the next like the easy momentum step
is you're already making the videos
once a week going live you have more
plans coming up which is great like i
love the the street science yeah that's
it it's street science atlanta street
science you go and you explain something
[Laughter]
but and it'd be a shame if you make
those videos and then they never get any
views because youtube then kills the the
the views on them so
uh even just that like go live and then
put it to unlisted afterwards
and then just edit the first two seconds
out or eight seconds or whatever
whatever the the junk is at the
beginning as you're getting ready and
then upload it again just as a as a
regular video without editing chapters
and all the other stuff
just to have it better for long term
yeah okay that makes sense okay thank
you for the the input there and it
doesn't mean you can't then go hire an
editor and do the rest of it later right
cool
but what what often happens is oh i
don't have an editor so then i can't do
it
and then nothing happens
no the uh i was talking there's a few
people that have been following me and
i started in june last year so i have uh
have a
youtube live that i've either lived or
i've re-uploaded the video so it's been
at least 52 weeks
so i'm proud it's the momentum the idea
of momentum i'm doing it once a week and
so it's very nice
i love it man i love it
well it's great to see you great to see
the smile thank you for bringing you're
kind of bringing the street science
already to us showing us very nice the
the beautiful i'm i'm jealous i love it
some views here so
so you don't have to travel very far you
just have to do ig live with people and
you're traveling at the same time
i love it ella thank you for your
positivity and and love and always i
appreciate you man and uh we'll talk to
you soon
thank you evan and take care all
movement makers take care bye-bye enjoy
your trip cheers man to see me coach
another entrepreneur one-on-one check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there i have three
audiences that i really can serve with
what i do i have organizational leaders
i have frontline leaders and i have
entrepreneurs
how do i
serve them all